let's let's let's talk about this first
story
uh it's a crazy story but i don't want
to i don't want to go hard on deep
cultural issues because we're going to
we're going to lose control of the feed
in about 10 minutes
so uh this from timcast.com
first texas bus
drops off illegal immigrants in
washington dc the convoy is part of
texas governor greg abbott's push to
secure the southern border and stem the
flow of illegal immigration from central
america so basically what happens is joe
biden's administration starts sending
illegal immigrants to communities in
texas people get really upset by this
for obvious reasons he's been doing it
all over the country even in the dead of
night the governor of texas said okay
i'll tell you what you want to do that
here i'm going to send these people to
dc
gen saki calls it a publicity stunt
then he actually does it ron de santa
says he's going to do the same thing but
send him up to delaware boom that was
going to be that's where they need to
send him exactly
it's not perfect right sending sending
people to delaware will just make people
in delaware upset but the point is like
hey biden's the one who's doing it so
why don't you guys get a taste here's
the thing i i'd be willing to believe
that biden's already sending illegal
immigrants to delaware and other states
they're all over the country so
well uh
i don't know if you guys have thoughts
on this because i'm curious of the
process do they do they just take them
on a bus and
pull up to a street and they just tell
them to scatter what
were they getting dropped off at my
understanding is they actually just
walked them off the bus and said have a
nice day whoa
yup that's wild yeah the people have all
uh agreed to go on the bus i believe too
this is only people that have acquiesced
they have agreed to go on the bus
so i wonder if that'll end up being an
endless supply of people
or will they run out of because it can't
just be a one-off because it is you know
jintaki if this is just a one-off
publicity stunt you get headlines but if
there's a steady stream of them being
dropped off in delaware in washington dc
you can keep that drum beat going and
people start experiencing what you know
has happened to
these states that are on the mexican
border uh if you can start really
feeling that experience in dc and in
delaware and other places the poli
biting these guys are going to have to
react
what's our immigration deal just
is the most bizarre it's not the most
bizarre because we have so many bizarre
things going on but one of these are the
top two we'll get to them all i'm sure
what is the delaware what's so hot about
being delaware being a destination
that's joe biden's state okay yeah
it's in his home state i see it getting
i you know
there's a there's an article from the
daily beast where they said it's
xenophobic
for for the republicans to do this what
and i'm just like hold on joe biden is
sending these people by force
on buses to texas
greg abbott is asking them if they want
to get on a bus to go to dc
so is is not what joe biden doing
xenophobic it's this is the game we've
been talking about a lot but it just it
happens the double standard it's an
endless conversation every day about the
double standard between what the the
administration the democrats the
establishment are allowed to do always
defended and anybody who counters in any
way is accused of all the worst
far-right whatever
i think
they would perhaps prefer to be in dc as
well it'll be easier to get your free
cell phones right there in dc there's
probably a direct connect they probably
got a deal set up with cricket or
somebody to get these people the free uh
cell phones they were promised i don't i
don't think it's fair to call him
xenophobe xenophobic personally i just
looked up the definition one unduly
fearful of what is foreign and
especially of people or foreign origin
so being unduly fearful of what is
foreign it's not that's i think a lot of
this isn't coming from fear of foreigner
it's that you disrupt the local economy
when you import people that don't
understand the culture or speak the
language
and you've got to be really careful
about disrupting your your economy the
united states is very young it hasn't
experienced a large immigration that
completely altered the government like
when people come in slowly and then all
of a sudden they're the ones that start
to get there they happened the roman
empire i mean it's the way the roman
empire fell really is the people the
barbarians from the north or whatever
they came in over hundreds years and
then now they're the government and then
yeah i don't know if i believe in hyper
xenophobia but
i am
probably xenophobic because
i want people that share my values
in this country i want people that
believe in freedom as the ultimate prize
not entitlement as the ultimate prize
our victimization as the ultimate prize
and again i don't know the people
flooding our our borders and immigrating
illegally maybe they do believe in
american freedom maybe that's why
they're they're coming here but i don't
think that's what the democrats and the
people leading our uh immigration policy
i don't think those are the values they
want them to have
uh i don't think you're xenophobic you
know they use these phobia words to make
you sound unreasonable and if you're
just saying i'm not look i'm personally
i'm not scared of people from central
south america or you even have people
from africa coming in i'm not scared of
any of these people in fact i know some
some people and they're they're good
people i hear you know trump said some
of them are good people right now the
reality is they want what a lot of
people want opportunity in america in
fact i have more respect for them and
their desires than i do for many of
these woke people in this country
there's one thing i am worried about is
the woke people but the issue of
xenophobia is that that's a ridiculous
term it's meant to obfuscate the real
conversation the real conversation is
there are economic limits to what you
can do with with people just coming
across whenever they want you end up
strangling the labor market you end up
flooding the labor market supply and
demand takes effect and then people's
wages get depressed there's challenges
there and then as you pointed out there
are there are a lot of people here who
want to be here and again i do respect
that desire to be in america because i
know how much this country rocks but if
they don't if they don't understand our
constitution if they don't understand
our values then it dilutes our values
and the things that made this country
great so if there's somebody who says
guys here's the recipe for a great cake
and then you say we're going to let 10
more bakers in who don't know how to
bake it but they're going to be involved
well then things are going to get a
little wishy-washy that's why my
attitude is always like let everybody
come everybody can can come but they
gotta wait in line like normal and go
through a standard process that way we
can make sure the recipe doesn't get
disrupted but we can have more cooks in
the kitchen just as long as everybody's
following the rules and we all agree on
how it's supposed to go it's not fear
it's actually
it's i would consider to be more
compassionate
so that you can make sure people can
thrive and that you're not just throwing
them into the middle of a desert where
these kids are are dying of dehydration
i think it you're talking about just
being responsible
and it's no different than who you would
allow into your home check if you got
kids wife husband whatever
uh you want to be a responsible
homeowner and so you just don't let any
and everybody into your home
that's the way i feel about america you
see these stories of the the refugee
crisis
and a lot of people are like you know
are you going to let
some of these refugees into your houses
many of these these left activists who
were very much like yeah we got to let
all the refugees in would not offer up
any of their homes now
i do personally know left-wing woke
activists who did and it was great
success and i'm like that's amazing that
you had the resources you had a plan
you were you were capable to do this not
everybody is asking a middle-class
family who's just scraping by paycheck
to paycheck to open their doors to
somebody that's what you're doing when
you're like let's have open borders
let's let's let's allow all these people
to come in yeah i get it you guys might
be in big cities with a higher cost of
standard of living a higher cost of
living you have more money but the poor
working class people who are paycheck to
paycheck it's straining their lives and
that's that's that's that's not that's
not okay right you gotta be you gotta
you gotta respect the working class
people
it's that whole concept of like the
the luxury belief where you can have
these beliefs because you're not really
incurring the cost directly you're sort
of exporting those costs to those around
you who are taking the brunt of the
policies you advocate for like the
people who are most likely to say
something like you know abolish the
police
they tend to be like upper-class white
people who have probably live in gated
communities these aren't the people who
are dealing in these these cities these
areas where there's high crime so it's
really easy for someone like that to say
you know these these platitudes that
really sound good to sort of give them
this credit to the people around them um
because again they're not incurring
these costs the guy named rob henderson
he coined that term let me oh i want to
add two just to back to the conversation
about the buses
bringing illegal immigrants into these
areas
just does exactly what democrats were
hoping was going to happen anyway that
you're going to increase the population
of a district which results in a larger
in the census resulting in a larger
population after the census and then
they'll get more congressional seats
more electoral seats so yeah send them
to dc send them you know dc maybe make
sense because they don't get
representation
sending sending uh people to delaware
just gives delaware more congressional
power and more electoral votes so the
real issue is you know people should be
welcome to this country with open arms
through a legal process that makes sure
they thrive and so do we
but i think i think the main issue is
people on the left they're not having
kids so they need to find ways that in
the next 20 years they will still have
voting power and that's by bringing in
new people who have a tendency to vote
for democratic policies and democratic
politicians
conservatives have kids liberals don't
so liberals need to go to the schools to
get your kids in line with their views
so they can conservative kids on their
side or they need to bring people in who
will side with them
reminds me of a netflix documentary that
i'll watch called wild wild country
it's about portland
or
area in oregon not portland but an area
in oregon it was taken over by
this indian hindu
uh
like no shot nosha
uh
he was basically a sex guru or whatever
and they started literally to gain
voting power and to take over this
section of of oregon they started
recruiting this happened in the 70s this
is like a real life story they started
bussing in people from los angeles
homeless people into this area so they
could change the voting demographics
in oregon so they could take over more
and and it ended up the homeless people
were on drugs and so many of them
violent and they actually turned on the
people that brought them there because
their needs weren't getting met
uh it's it's one of the best
greatest documentaries i've ever seen
because it happened in the 70s and
explained to everything that's going on
today it takes time and they're willing
to invest the time
so if someone who is eight years old
today gets indoctrinated in a school
they're voting in 10 years
so it's it's a long game we can't think
in in short term cycles like two and
four years you got to think ahead you
got to think 10 20 years someone born
today
more likely to be conservative because
of just standard demographics of
conservatives having kids liberals not
and also having abortions so you got 18
years until conservatives get that
advantage how do you counter that they
know this
they play the long game conservatives i
think you know um
the the the the uh politically minded
politically uh
careered
are probably thinking about this on the
conservative side i think regular people
miss this you know they don't understand
necessarily why the schools do what they
do when they go after kids
a lot of what the left is doing seems
desperate to me
and it makes me think that they think
they only have a limited amount of time
to execute their plan
before
the whole thing collapses in on them
yeah i was thinking how much of it is
desperation how much of it is instinct
like
seems like humans have an instinct to
parent i don't know i do i don't know if
you guys do i feel like i just love kids
i wanted to help kids uh and and so i
was like well if i never actually have
kids what's reproduction if i make a
bunch of videos and there's a bunch of
copies of it that i'm forming some sort
of reproduction that will affect society
and maybe i can help the children that
way very leftist mentality you know it's
very much like what we see now and i
wonder if it's just like they really
want to help but and then they're but
they're so twisted that they're trying
to help by you know infusing these
specific ideals
or if they actually want to hurt people
i i'm not getting the vibe that they
want to hurt people uh it just seems
more like a communist uh they want power
mental shift if it's like taking hold of
these people or something they don't
know communist is the right word they
want power and they're not afraid to
they're not they're not afraid to
inflict collateral damage on people to
get it
i think that's true of anyone you know
but i think there's a tendency what we
see with the establishment the
democratic party and even the uniparty
republican types what's happened is
there's been a populist uprising also on
the left i think a lot of the bernie
people many of them moved over nine
million obama voters moved over to voted
for trump it's really just about
populism
we we had steve bannon saying he was far
right and then he says text the rich and
i'm like i don't know that's far right
dude i think that's actually a left
position but it's just a populist
position it's about are you in support
of elites telling you what to do and how
to live or do you think the people we
the people should decide and and form
our own government
we the people were you say jason i well
i was going to piggyback ian am i right
are you an atheist or agnostic more
agnostic than anything okay and so what
i see from the left honestly is just
they think that
they're secular so they think they're
god
and
uh it's just a power grab and and again
did you probably watch the or saw a
little bit of like game of thrones
and game of thrones is just this story
when it was good the first four or five
seasons about what human beings will do
for power in anything they'll do
anything for power and that and
particularly if you don't have some kind
of religious belief some kind of faith
in a higher power and you think
you're capable of being the ultimate
decider
it puts you in a very bad you'll do very
bad things for power because you have so
much belief in your ability to control
things and do what's best for other
people
and i just don't have that kind of
arrogance because
i believe i'm just a very tiny
insignificant part of this thing that
god put together
and
you know i don't want that kind of power
i literally want to stick to the
principles taught in the bible
and and you know
hope for the best and hope that i'm
right
uh and i i just see
the the left is so secular
and and they see themselves as god
that's what scares us what makes me
nervous about the churches i feel like
the the church has acted as now they are
the mouthpiece of god it's like another
form of secularism almost like who cares
about a building and a guy that tells
you he's a priest but god's real god's
out there god is an energy field flowing
like it's it's there it's always there
you don't need someone to to
you don't need to like be told you don't
need authority to tell you that what
about your relationship with god i feel
the church out of it i feel it i i
science has helped me see the cosmic
microwave background radiation for
instance it's this web of energy i left
over after the big bang you see it
arcing through star systems and then you
feel your heart beating it's getting
like
the heat is coming from without like
it's we're getting these electrical
currents pumping through us and after i
started to see i
smoke a lot of weed that helped a lot
and to feel the heat and then you can
feel your own heat and i'm like wow did
jesus do reiki and then you see that
jesus like went off maybe to india for
some period in his early life and and
studied like
hinduism and reiki and came back as like
a healer so i started doing reiki and
that's real let me let me throw in there
i think i actually enjoy when when ian
and sheamus talk about religious stuff
because he uh sheamus comes from a more
like um
what's the right word uh he he's he's
devout you know he goes to mass ian has
a bunch of ideas about spirituality that
i think need to be answered and and it
creates something interesting i think i
certainly think ian sees or feels
something that
you know needs to be answered or defined
and maybe maybe there's a
in the more rigid structures
people have thought about these things
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you